you clicked on a video called my least
work ball congratulations you must be
bored out of your [ __ ] mind
good Arda skating I am bored out of my
[ __ ] mind replaced so you bros have
been crazy about me playing this game
it's been tweeted to me about five
million times so the objective is help
Miley twerk that ball what am i doing
why God is this what I was meant to do
make Miley twerk wha there's one thing
you need to know about working if you
got to twerk it you better goddamn twerk
it good how this is work [ __ ]
nice oh thanks
okay side it'll hurt but my leg stop
tracking my leg I'm working it's it's
working hahahaha
how do you even make that face I don't
know what's more sad me playing it or
you watching it this is a bruise Oh ball
poor ball
I never wanted to play this game I
wanted to have a normal life woulda
thought he would end up in Miley Cyrus
ass what he just killed himself it gives
me the worst it's so poorly coded so it
gives me like the worst like spike what
is that it looks like a chicken moving
back and forth
I'm not even playing the game I'm just
[ __ ] dizzy Miley I'm gonna make a
hundred twerks I'm gonna make a thousand
works target oh yeah
jiggle dumb ass cheeks that's what you
do this is literally your job Miley make
your money's worth [ __ ] met Buffett
goal you don't even have an ass okay the
song is actually not bad when Miley
isn't singing it but footy healthy jab
like you expected of canola it I can't
beat tent works my life has no meaning
10:12 my [ __ ] god ah it looks like a
[ __ ] alien if you focus on the ads it
looks like this let's try and beat 100
we can be 200 I know it because I know
that why would you twerk a ball anyway
it kind of looks like a the ball is a
head you ever see it
good I have no life I need friends I'm
gonna keep going until we hit 100 that
is the rule and we never gonna get oh so
it counts as a twerk even though she
ain't working it
gotcha I don't have to jiggle the ass to
twerk very interesting duly noted
I wonder if KFC sells Miley Cyrus I
wonder if she tastes good it's probably
all boney man I should be a philosopher
or some [ __ ] like that
a twerking philosophy I like it
why not this is Meghan land on our ass
and jig a little bit my head bang it
really looks like some sort of alien
when you're moving like this why my
leave I don't Detroit
I never thought I'd say those words keep
talking keep talking keep talking Oh
black ink this is awkward I don't think
it is
holy [ __ ] on Miley Cyrus butt cheeks I
find a tactic that works
come on my truckin will pierce the
heavens one day one day one life one
love all right it's working if I twerk a
lot parking is a solution of everything
you look like a chicken chickens don't
work at least not in the dictionary I'm
not sure actually I'll have to check on
that doesn't matter
gonna beat 45 [ __ ] gotta be a hundred
pork keep trucking I got the hang of
this [ __ ]
this gave me surprisingly addicting I
don't know why I'm actually enjoying
playing this game hey I'm good at
working [ __ ] you you don't know you
probably know me if you watch my video
whatever
come on 100 trucks ha ha ha
come on no we did not drag this far to
twerk die you [ __ ] Oh aah
that's the oil again my stew I can tell
it works
sorry no don't flutter jump that same
though that's twerk same oh my [ __ ]
god oh my [ __ ] god ten more of a like
the pavel dancing Vimala the weather I
make a lot of jokes on this channel but
twerking is dead [ __ ] serious I'm
sorry for doing this to your ball I
really am
69 so if I time the tort properly it
doesn't change direction one direction
Illuminati it all makes sense but why
aren't you watching symmetric like every
goddamn human being Miley I'm sorry to
make you feel awkward if your butt
cheeks aren't symmetric you know what
that's okay I don't look at you
different day there's a drinking game
for you watch this video and drink every
time I say to work alright I'm gonna
give this one final try it I'm [ __ ]
sick of this [ __ ]
alright one try